[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans
audition publique les jeux sont presque
faits tout va aller très vite désormais
avant le premier tour dimanche après les
questions de sécurité de santé les
questions d'europe on va ce soir faire
un gros plan sur les questions sociales
bonsoir laurent berger merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous vous êtes secrétaire
national de la cfdt le pouvoir d'achat
est finalement la préoccupation des
français en cette fin de campagne et il
y a de bonnes raisons à cela la hausse
spectaculaire des carburants qui plombe
le portefeuille hausse partiellement
compensé par l'état elle est elle
suffisamment l'inflation a atteint 4 et
demi pour cent en ce mois de mars
comment répondre la france amorti mieux
que ses voisins est ce que les décisions
qui ont été prises ont été appropriées
bien ajusté on parle si peu d'emplois
dans cette campagne pourquoi est-ce que
la bataille du chômage et gagner selon
vous on parle en revanche beaucoup
retraite travailler plus longtemps est
ce que c'est inévitable
quelles sont vos priorités pour le
prochain quinquennat tout à l'heure
brigitte boucher et tentera nous y
viendrons vous poser toutes ces
questions avec yves thréard le
syndicalisme at il de l'avenir bonnes
questions philo c'est une question qu'il
vous posera directement de l'avenir quel
que soit le prochain président là aussi
où lui répondrais et puis vincent roux
vous interpellera sur une question
d'actualité en direct du fier en live
mais d'abord ensemble on va commencer
par évidemment l'ukraine puisqu'on a
découvert ont plutôt on a on a vu à
travers les documents des journalistes
sur place des atrocités qui s'ajoute à
la guerre déjà meurtrière on est au
40ème jour laurent berger des atrocités
notamment à bout cha les cadavres
jonchent les rues on en découvre dans
les caves des indices laissent penser à
des crimes de guerre qui auraient
perpétré les russes en quittant
certaines localités en partant de kiev
d'abord est ce que vous pensiez cela
possible
non je pense qu'aucun d'entre nous
pensaient que sur notre continent on
allait vivre ce qu'avait été déjà vécu
c'est à dire cette horreur 7 ces
exécutions sommaires ces crimes de
guerre c'est l'effroi qui nous saisit
c'est l'horreur et puis c'est cette idée
après très vite que il faut pas
détourner le regard et de pas détourner
le regard ça veut dire prendre
conscience de ce qui est sûr c'est qu'on
en train de se passer est d'avoir deux
exigences qui me semble fondamental la
première c'est la justice il faudra que
la justice passe il faudra que la
justice internationale passe seconde
c'est comment on fait pour arrêter ça
quelle est l'action de la communauté
internationale pour aller plus loin pour
arrêter ça et je crois que il faut de
nouvelles sanctions des sanctions
renforcées se pose la question même si
elle est difficile la question de de se
priver du gaz russe pour peser davantage
sur poutine pour l'empêcher d'aller vous
vous êtes pour un embargo sur le gaz
russe maintenant vous avez vu sans doute
les allemands encore dit tout à l'heure
qu'il ne pouvait pas se passer de gazon
est-ce que je vous pose une question un
peu solennel mais franchement est ce que
l'europe se déshonorerait aujourd'hui à
différer encore cette décision mais je
crois que ce qui s'est passé ce week-end
qui est un cran supplémentaire dans
l'horreur avait déjà de l'horreur il y
avait déjà cette guerre elle a été déjà
terrible cette agression russell et des
ailes étaient déjà terrible il ya un
cran supplémentaire je crois que ce à
quoi est appellé l'europe c'est un delà
de la force pour contester cette
agression russe et donc se donner le
moyen de le faire et je crois que couper
le gaz russe est un moyen de le faire
même si évidemment c'est difficile parce
que il en naît d'un devoir moral et donc
il faut de la force et de l'unité au
niveau européen parce que il en est oui
c'est je crois que c'est un devoir moral
enfin c'est ce qui se passe on sait pas
si ça s'est produit dans d'autres
localités encore mais juste ce qui s'est
passé ce qui est juste pour dire déjà ce
qui s'est passé c'est terrible et je
crois qu'il va falloir se poser la
question parce que tout le monde
comprend qu'il ne peut pas y avoir d
escalade militaire c'est pas souhaitable
c'est mais il peut pas y avoir d'inertie
non plus il peut pas y avoir de
passivité et donc moi je souhaite que
l'europe réfléchisse très très vite très
vite et agissent très très vite pour se
regarder comment aux frappes au
porte-monnaie poutine pour pas qu'ils
puissent continuer cette guerre et ça ce
qui vient évidemment en premier et je
sais les difficultés
c'est évidemment de ceux d'en bas en
parler vous qu'être sensible aux
questions sociales con et le gaz coupé
toutes ses sources d'approvisionnement
ça aura des conséquences aussi pour les
français plus pour d'autres mais aussi
pour les français mais juste avant vous
dites que il faut absolument que
l'europe donc réagissent à ce niveau là
ce serait pour vous approprier
si elle ne le fait pas laurent berger si
elle prend des sanctions qui sont moins
importantes moins douloureuse pour nous
est-ce que elle donne un blanc seing à
poutine est ce que vous pensez qu'elle
donne le la poutine vous pouvez
continuer comme ça monsieur le chef du
kremlin laurent l'europe a réagi ce dont
il est question l'europe a réagi elle a
réagi pour tenter de stopper de ralentir
l'action que menait que mène poutine
contre l'ukraine visiblement ça ne
suffit pas
visiblement ça ne suffit pas donc il
faut aller plus loin et je ne parle pas
d'un je ne parle pas d'un déshonneur de
l'europe si jamais elle le faisait pas
j'incite tient vite j'incite à ce que
l'europe le fasse comment ça peut se
faire j'entends ce que vous dites sur
les conséquences pour les citoyens
européens la conséquence moral la
conséquence historiens pont bien sûr
qu'elle est bien pire parce que le
consentement à l'horreur le consentement
à ces crimes de guerre est un est un
déshonneur mais plus qu un déshonneur ça
nous ça nous emmène encore plus loin et
donc je crois que l'europe comment elle
peut répondre de façon unie on a su
faire face au co vide rien à voir
évidemment mais avoir quand même sur les
conséquences sociales économiques que ça
avait provoqué l'europe s'est unie à ce
moment là pour un fonds d'urgence pour
réagir pour soutenir les entreprises
pour soutenir les travailleurs pour
soutenir les pays dans l'eure dans leur
protection sociale dans l'eure dans leur
soutien à leurs populations eh bien je
crois que c'est de ça dont il s'agit
c'est de cela dont il s'agit aujourd'hui
et est ce que la réponse est simple
arrête je veux tout de suite je vous le
dit non c'est pas ça la bulgarie est
très dépendant jeudi l'allemagne dit non
oui oui mais je sais tout ça mais ce que
ce oui mais ce que je vous dise et des
femmes des hommes des enfants massacrés
aujourd'hui ces exécutions sommaires des
mères une mère qui est retrouvé dans un
dans une fosse commune dd voilà c'est ça
la réalité donc vous voyez on peut pas
parler exactement sur la même échelle on
prend et donc c'est ça dont il s'agit
aujourd'hui il n'est pas son de faire du
donneur de leçons savez personne peut se
le permettre c'est pas simple
aujourd'hui je crois des dirigeants en
europe et de faire face à sète à cette
guerre et à cette agression russe parce
que il ya beaucoup d'éléments compliqué
que sans doute je ne maîtrise pas demain
non plus d'ailleurs mais ce qui est sûr
c'est que ce qui s'est passé cette
semaine ce week-end ne peut pas rester
sans réaction de la part de l'europe de
façon unie et y compris pour faire face
aux conséquences et la prise au terme de
sanction contre la russie en fait
conscience vous fait confiance enfin
vous pensez qu emmanuel macron a
suffisamment leadership sur l'europe et
président l'union européenne pour
convaincre les récalcitrants
mais je crois je crois que l'europe
s'est plutôt bien comporté depuis le
début avec sans doute des lenteurs et
est haute mais depuis le début de
l'agression russe contre l'ukraine je
fais confiance aux dirigeants européens
quel qu'il soit pour aller dans la bonne
direction je fais confiance à madame von
der leyen qui aujourd'hui a proposé par
exemple que l'europe allait enquêter sur
ces crimes de guerre je fais confiance
aux différents dirigeants européens pas
quel qu'il soit pour essayer de trouver
l'unité pour pour faire face vous savez
on est face à un moment on va parler de
tout à l'heure des questions sociales et
des accords des désaccords là on est
face à un modèle qui est celui de
l'europe le modèle de la démocratie le
modèle des droits fondamentaux du
respect des femmes et des hommes face à
un autre modèle qui est celui de
l'autocratie presque de la dictature et
de l'horreur et du non respect de la vie
humaine c'est de ça dont il s'agit est
donc dans ces cas là oui je crois je
sais plus quel côté je me situe du côté
de l'europe
alors on est dans ce contexte que vous
avez décrit avec des mots très forts
nous en france on a une campagne
électorale une campagne spéciale pas
comment vous la qualifiez non-campagne
campagne empêcher escamoté bon
est ce que ça vous inquiète qu'on soit
obligés d'aller voter dimanche qu'on
soit obligé à y faire notre devoir de
voter
et on dire un mot de l'abstention après
mes dents avec ce voile à ce poids là de
l'actualité internationale c'est quand
même pas banal c'est pas banal donc
c'est une campagne particulière mais
dimanche nous avons la chance d'aller
pouvoir voter moi je suis le président
de la confédération européenne des
syndicats et donc seront bien avec pas
mal de mes collègues un peu partout dans
le monde nous avons la chance d'aller
voter nous avons la chance qu
individuellement chacun et chacune
d'entre vous d'entre nous notre voix
porte à elle porte pour un parce que
nous sommes un mais collectivement et
elle porte est donc cette campagne elle
est évidemment particulière liée à la
guerre en ukraine on sent effectivement
plus de distance une forme de fatigue
démocratique de l'envié des avants et
des années presque
sans doute pas tort mais moi je me
résous pas je me résous pas donc ce que
j'ai envie de dire aujourd'hui c'est
deux choses 1 il faut aller voter
dimanche cette campagne a été
particulière les sujets on va y revenir
ont en partie été évoqués quand même
nous on a on apprend sortie cette
campagne a quand même le sujet vont
d'ailleurs la question du pouvoir
d'achat le sujet de l'action publique
est sorti a pas assez mais on a parlé un
petit peu d'environnement donc voyez et
on a parlé un peu d'europe situation
aussi oblige donc un certain nombre de
sujets c'est ça peut être un parfait
saleh il ya une forme de fatigue
l'abstention
faut aller voter il faut aller voter et
ensuite il faudra continuer à peser
parce que la démocratie ne se résume pas
à l'élection la démocratie c'est une
démocratie on continue et il faudra je
crois qu on fasse davantage avec tous
ceux qui aujourd'hui sont la société ce
qui s'organise pour la poêle pour
construire du commun que ce soit dans
les associations et organisations
syndicales dans les collectivités et
c'est ce que ce qu'on a compris
aujourd'hui j'espère en tout cas moi ce
que je dis depuis des années et ce qu'on
voit sous nos yeux c'est que les
citoyens sont un peu fatigués de cet
exercice démocratique dont ils
comprennent pas forcément toujours le
sens donc le premier message est allé
voter dimanche le deuxième c'est les
choix il faudra pas que ça puisse se
faire sans vous il faudra peser
s'organiser collectivement pour que ça
soit avec vous revitaliser démocratie on
y reviendra peut-être avec il frère tout
à l'heure juste un mot marine le pen
n'étant on s'en tient aux sondages
aujourd'hui enfin en très bonne voie de
se qualifier pour le deuxième tour ce ne
sera pas la première fois mais d'après
les sondages n'est pas loin des manuels
macro si c'est son adversaire si c'était
lui aussi qui se qualifiait dimanche on
ne sait pas mais elle serait pas loin
non plus de pouvoir être élu enfin en
tout cas l echa disons 47 53 marine le
pen emmanuel macron elle a des réserves
de voix inédites elle ne fait plus peur
est ce qu'on entend beaucoup marine le
pen elle ne vous fait plus peur si elle
ne me fait pas peur je combats l'extrême
droite et l'extrême droite oui allez
d'extrême droite bien sûr sur la
question de la société l'ouverture de la
société et la question migratoire elle
est d'extrême droite sur la conception
du contre-pouvoir dans une démocratie
elle est d'extrême droite dans ses
alliances internationales elle était la
première à soutenir à féliciter urban
elle est ambiguë
elle est allée ambigu sur la relation
avec poutine elle est d'extrême droite
je crois sur un enjeu très fort que
celui de la lutte contre les
discriminations donc sur sa conception
de la démocratie des rôles de des
contre-pouvoirs je les ai déjà dit donc
aller d'extrême droite le match n'est
pas joué il faut que tout citoyen a une
voix peut aller voter selon ses
convictions dimanche donc on verra ce
qu'il en sera ce qui est sûr et qui est
sûr pour la cfdt je le dis depuis des
mois jeudi des fluides et moi c'est quel
que soit le candidat qui sera en face de
marine le pen ou d'eric zemmour si
c'était le cas pour l'un ou pour l'autre
au sol après le second tour enfin avant
le second tour la cdt dira qu'il faut
que l'extrême droite ne n'accède pas au
pouvoir dans ce pays et donc il faudra
voter pour l'autre candidat ou l'autre
candidate c'est clair net ou simplement
parce que les valeurs qui sont celles du
syndicaliste ne sont pas compatibles
avec les valeurs de l'extrême droite qui
sont portées par madame le pen et
monsieur zemmour vous voulez beaucoup
sur le terrain vous déplacer beaucoup
vous allez voir les entreprises les
antennes de la scène santé ça vous
sentez que ça peut basculer dans le sens
que vous redoutez et on a parlé de
fatigue démocratique on a eu le
sentiment d'un certain nombre de 6 il ya
un certain nombre de citoyens qui ont le
sentiment d'être un visibiliser ne pas
être considérés etc oui on le sent ça on
le sent on sent des citoyens qui sont
fatigués qu'ils sont un peu soient
désintéressés de la campagne soit en
colère soit qu'ils sont préoccupés par
leur situation concrète qui sont celles
qui sont liées au pouvoir d'achat
d'achat au pouvoir de vivre qui sont
liés à d'autres problématiques de
cocktail que le logement donc on sent
moi je suis pas prévisionnistes suis pas
politologue je suis pas fait pas de
sondages mais on sent que tout est
possible dans cette élection
donc le message de la qualité
extrêmement extrêmement claire nous ne
nions pas de consigne de vote nous ne
donnons pas de consigne de vote chacun
vote selon ses convictions mais nous
sommes libres et engagé à éliminer
l'extrême droite n'est pas une option
pour nous très clairement je le dis nous
sommes des syndicalistes nous sommes
engagés sur des valeurs qui sont des
valeurs démocratiques des valeurs de
justice sociale des valeurs de vivre
ensemble et c'est pas compatible et que
ce soit moi si ça se passait tout alors
comment vous réagirez mais n'allons pas
trop vite en besogne dans un instant les
questions concrètes elles vont vous est
posée elles concernent les français mais
d'abord on va rejoindre vincent roux qui
est en direct du feel your life bonsoir
vincent merci d'être avec une question
sur une affaire qu'il faut et beaucoup
qui fait beaucoup parler
oui il ya beaucoup de commentaires
bonsoir laurent berger tour de la ferme
ce qu'on pourrait appeler la sphère
maquis c'est après la planquette du
sénat beaucoup de commentaires également
sur les déclarations de patrimoine des
manuels macro moi je voudrais qu'on
vient sur la sueur mcit c est ce que les
informations qui nous parviennent et en
particulier de l'enquète parlementaire
nécessite selon vous
l'ouverture d'une enquête du parquet
national financier
ça je suis pas très qualifiés pour en
parler je peux vous parler de comment je
réagis quand comme tout le monde on
apprend que la facture un cabinet de
conseil est aussi élevé sur a fortiori
quand c'est un cabinet de conseil qui
apparemment ne paye pas ses impôts en
france c'est pas nouveau c'est pas
nouveau que l'action publique fasse
appel à des experts moi ce que je
regrette c'est pas que de temps en temps
on fasse appel à des experts ce que je
pense ce que je regrette c'est que
parfois dans la façon de gouverner on
articule pas de richesses qui sont
celles de notre pays la première c'est
une autre fonction publique où il y a
des compétences et qui sont parfois
capables de se priver d'experts bien
souvent de ce cas priver d'experts parce
qu'il ya une autre fonction publique qui
tient la route de notre pays avec des
gens compétents que c est qui pourrait
s'appuyer plutôt que de s'appuyer sur
des experts sur une autre richesse qui
est celle de l' expertise du quotidien
de l expertise de la réalité de
l'externat retisse de terrain qui est
celle de ses citoyens qui s'organise
dans des associations des organismes
syndicale etc qui ont la propre
expertise et donc des fois je suis un
peu choqué qu'on puisse faire appel à
des experts et je parle en cale général
quand finalement les solutions sont
celles de ceux qui vivent des situations
c'est donc et donc je crois qu'il y à
une somme qui est très élevé pour ce
cabinet encore une fois c'est pas un
fait nouveau on l'a connu
dans les dernier quinquennat de façon
assez
mais ça nous arrive oui jamais mais bien
sûr c'est pas c'est pas quelque chose de
choquant de faire appel et cabinet ce
que ce que je crois par exemple nom
maxime s'est fait pas partie des parts
mais vous savez mais mais mais mais mais
encore une fois mais vous savez nous on
fait des équipes d'entreprises dans les
enfants dans les entreprises elles font
appel à des cabinets pour travailler sur
la qualité de vie au travail pour
travailler pour expertiser sur les
contrats
7,5 et contestataire il ya une question
du volume et à la question il ya la
question très clairement est-ce que ça a
remplacé la démocratie sociale est-ce
que ça a remplacé ce que des citoyens
organisés d orgue d organisation
collective savent très bien expertisé
parce que c'est leur réalité leur
quotidien et le connaissent voilà et
donc des fois il faut pas théoriser les
solutions il faut les construire avec
les populations concernées petite
relance il ya des fois ça a été ça n a
pas été le cas est-ce que parfois le
recours à ces cabinets de conseil n'a
pas été nécessité parce qu'ils ont été
peut-être plus efficace que les agents
du service public
non je crois pas non non les agents du
service public vous savez on a vécu deux
ans de saint pandémie où ils ont prouvé
leur efficacité je crois que en tout
point de vue c'est vrai sur la question
de la santé c'est vrai sur la question
de l'éducation c'est vrai sur la
question de la justice est vrai sur la
question des services du quotidien et
bien les agents publics ils savent
lorsqu'on leur donne les moyens et
l'enroulé considère on va en parler il
s'alarme répondre aux besoins des
populations merci beaucoup vincent euros
merci à la semaine prochaine en face de
vous vous les connaissez projet bush et
entre nous et cet homme qui commence et
oui on va parler de questions concrètes
a le pouvoir d'achat c'est la première
préoccupation des français alors face à
l'as l'inflation l'augmentation des prix
à la pompe le gouvernement a prévu donc
cette baisse de 18 centimes sur le
carburant elle est appliquée depuis
vendredi dernier à ce que c'est pour
vous la bonne réponse
c'est une réponse façon lorsque vous
êtes représentant des travailleurs comme
moi vous pouvez pas dire que c'est pas
une bonne réponse lorsqu'on essaie
d'amoindrir le coût du carburant pour
ceux/celles qui vont travailler au moins
je les dis dès le départ je trouve que
c'est pas assez ciblées si elle trouve
que c'est pas assez ciblées le vrai le
problème qui est posé aujourd'hui c'est
ses déplacements du quotidien pour
nombre de travailleurs et travailleuses
lorsqu'ils se rendent au travail
lorsqu'il faut parce qu'ils sont loin
d'un certain nombre de 2,2 de deux
centres urbains où il faut aller emmener
les enfants à l'école etc ça s'apaise
beaucoup oui ce qui nous revient
beaucoup madame martichoux parlais tout
à l'heure de mes visites sur le terrain
ce qui remonte beaucoup c'est lorsque
vous faites 20 30 km pour aller
travailler ben là pour 1 en ce moment ça
coûte très très cher fallu dès
que ces personnes là celle-là je crois
que c'est beaucoup dans les entreprises
que ça peut se passer les des réflexions
sur les plans de mobilité là le
dz ponctuelle des entreprises sur les
déplacements pour venir travailler c'est
ce que c'est ce que tout le monde passe
à trottiner thériault si ça se travaille
aussi dans les collectivités et dans les
collectivités et les déplacements les
mobilités elle se gère à l'échelle
géographique mais dans les campagnes à
beaucoup de personnes qui prennent leur
voiture sont accompagnés d'enfants
que les travailleurs qui ont besoin
d'abris
je vais t'aider il apparaît une mesure
globale mais les travailleurs doivent
être aidés par des mesures ciblées des
façons notamment oui des collectivités
mais aussi dans les entreprises saillie
dans les entreprises moi j'étais l'autre
jour en discuter avec des salariés d'un
abattoir ils me disaient les horaires
sont échelonnées bas est ce que façon
temporaire on peut rediscuter des
horaires pour que les gens qu'on voiture
quand ils sont à 20 km ils sont à un
kilomètre ou deux ils sont à une
demi-heure de différences en termes
d'embauché est ce qu'on peut réfléchir à
ça la réponse est oui si on veut les
aider et aider et donc il faut qu'il y
ait eu un peu d'imagination pour aider
aux déplacements et évidemment l'idée
c'est pas d'aller mettre des bus là où
c'est plus c'est très dispersé mais
c'est d'aider ces ménages passée
particulièrement et ses travailleurs ce
qui est ce que vous êtes d'accord avec
ce que propose geoffroy roux de bézieux
le patron du medef il veut que les
entreprises puissent verser à leurs
salariés gros rouleurs des chèques
carburant défiscaliser bas qu'il le
fasse qu'elle le fasse et pourquoi pas
sa politique salariale dont on va parler
j'imagine tout à l'heure mais vous savez
défiscaliser en l'occurrence dans cette
période là sur cet angle là moi je suis
pas tout le monde le sait un pro la
défiscalisation de la défiscalisation et
notamment quand il s'agit des heures
supplémentaires par exemple j'y suis
opposée parce que je crois que la
fiscalisation ou la cotisation c'est
pour créer du commun soit des services
publics soit de la protection sociale en
l'occurrence là dans un contexte très
particulier que des entreprises versent
des primes
défiscalisé à carbure des chèques
carburant alors salariée oui ça remplace
pas la politique salariale il faut
qu'ils le fassent et mais il faut que ce
soit un peu incitatif il faut que les
entreprises se sont un peu contrainte de
le faire et plus globalement on est
aujourd'hui dans un contexte où il ya
effectivement une explosion des prix de
l'énergie qu'est ce que vous dites à
ceux qui conseillent d'aller vers plus
de sobriété énergétique est ce que vous
êtes d'accord avec eux oui ça a beaucoup
fait réagir quand j'ai dit ça d'ailleurs
je suis d'accord et on parle pas des 12
millions de personnes dans notre pays
qui vivent en précarité énergétique cela
ils font mal malgré eux contrôleurs qui
sont déjà dans la sobriété ils sont mus
gaza ils sont même
l'austérité et la pauvreté donc c'est
pas de cela n'en ont pas mais pour
d'autres pour nous
la question
la sobriété elle est posée et c'est pas
un gros mot la sobriété
le rapport du giec le rapt
le rapport du giec daugeard d'un tiers
le rapport du giec aujourd'hui le
rapport du giec aujourd'hui il dit il y
à déjà d'abord il ya des choses qui
avancent c'est devenu mon une
préoccupation mondiale mais il alerte
quand même énormément il al'air t il en
disant il ya une partie de
delà de la solution qui se fera par des
économies d'énergie et de la sobriété la
sobriété c'est quoi oui c'est peut-être
voir comment on se déplace quand c'est
pas pour des besoins totalement
essentiel c'est pas absolument
scandaleux d'interroger ça mais c'est
pas nouveau vous savez j'ai grandi dans
une période où on parlait d'économie
d'énergie dans des campagnes nationales
le premier choc pétrolier il s'est pas
totalement
cinq ans
puis après voilà et donc il y as je
pense vraiment qu'il ya une question
autour de la de ces mobilités mais aussi
de la façon dont on coupe à certains
moments on fait attention à sa
consommation de gaz à sa consommation
enfin je sais que ça peut choquer mais
vous savez ce qui est en train de se
passer là y compris sur la hausse du
carburant qui a accéléré et de l'énergie
qui a accéléré évidemment par
l'agression russe en ukraine de toute
façon c'est une question qui était posée
en soit sur la transition énergétique
alors moi je veux bien qu'on puisse
faire
les brassées dans tous les sens et puis
dire bah oui il faut de la transition
écologique mais il n'y aura pas aucune
conséquence y'aura pas des fosses à ce
qu'il faut ça accompagner les ménages
les plus modestes c'est accompagner les
ménages plus modestes et puis que
collectivement se disent qu'il ya un
enjeu là qui et quoi qu un an j'ai juste
pour nos enfants juste pour nos enfants
est là le ce que dit le rapport du giec
c'est pas pour nos arrières arrières
petits enfants ça va ça va se dérouler
de façon extrêmement compliqué c'est
pour nos enfants donc c'est pas un gros
mot la sobriété à condition que ce soit
pas la sobriété pour ceux qui la
subissent malgré avec ce soit pour un
autre c'est que ce soit accompagné alors
le smic va augmenter de 2,4 2 6% sous
l'effet de la hausse des prix c'est
mécanique est-ce que ça va permettre de
faire face à cette inflation ces hausses
de prix que vous constatez un peu
partout le smic il augmente de façon
automatique
vous savez l'augmentation du smic
annoncées au 1er mai elle va faire que
147 branches professionnelles soient les
171 branches professionnelles de plus de
5000 salariés 147 vont avoir des
échelons qui vont démarrer en dessous le
smic qui va se passer en fait c'est oui
le smic il faudrait il faut le
revaloriser parce qu'il ya une inflation
mais ce qu'il faut c'est revaloriser
l'ensemble des greer par ce qui est ma
façon et là il ya une responsabilité du
patronat et ce qui va se passer au 1er
mai est inédit on n'a jamais eu autant
de branches professionnelles dont le
début des grilles va être en soule en
dessous de ce pic ça veut dire qu'on va
mais
jamais autant
utilisation la revalorisation du smic
qui est bienvenu c'est perdre et perdre
y compris des temps des branches où on a
fait des négociations
depuis le mois d'octobre novembre et
avec des augmentations salariales obtenu
ça n'a pas été le cas malheureusement
toutes les branches et bien il faudra
revenir bien que hi la nécessité de
clause de retour d'une certaine manière
donc il va falloir que dans toutes les
branches ont ça on allait là dessus et
moi je sais ce que je souhaite c'est que
le gouvernement quel qu'il soit eh bien
ils imposent aux branches
professionnelles dans les six mois
d'avoir des négociations pour que leurs
minima de branche ne soit pas inférieur
au smic et 147 sur 171 est ce qu'il faut
en plus de cette hausse automatique un
coup de pouce pour le smic
oui ça peut franchement on est dense et
il ya une difficulté mais il d'abord il
faut une revalorisation du smic elle est
à coup sûr et il peut y avoir un coup de
pouce c'est pas un problème mais moi je
crois qu'on a des bas paresseux sur les
salaires de notre pays on pense le on
pense les salaires notre pays que par
cas en fonction du smic ce que je vous
dis très concret gta à la msa aimé ça
ouais il ya vingt ans à la msa mutualité
sociale agricole on veut y travailler
c'était on est c'était quelque chose de
haut se sentait reconnu et c'est
aujourd'hui à la msa il ya trois
échelons qui en dessous le smic trois
échelons sur huit échelons en tout ça
veut dire que vous restez trois ans en
dessous du smic avec une compensation
quand vous passez l'échelon vous faites
quoi vous restez explique donc le
problème du smic c'est que c'est pas une
normalement normalement on doit se fixer
un salaire d'embauché salaire minimum
salaire minimum d'embauché pour des gens
peu qualifiés ou pas qualifiée car
maintenant c'est de ces sales and risk
ça devient de plus en plus la norme il y
avait au jour autour il ya aujourd'hui
autour de deux millions de personnes qui
sont payés au smic 65 soit plus de 60%
sont des femmes 1 quand même et ça veut
dire que petit à petit on va aller de
plus en plus vers de plus en plus de
gens c'est
le smi qui joue plus son rôle de salaire
minimum le smic il est devenu trop
souvent la norme y compris quand vous
développer des compétences quand vous
avez un déroulement de carrière etc et
bien vous pouvez faire preuve d'
investissement professionnel de
compétences acquises évidemment par
votre travail etc et continuer d'être
payés au smic parce que finalement vous
montez
on vit correctement avec un smic mais on
vit pas correctement avec un smic en
france surtout avec une inflation comme
ça mais on vit pas correctement avec la
plupart des échelons des 147 franchement
est ce que je peux vous dire c'est que
là il ya une responsabilité du patronat
du patronat de reconnaître les
compétences professionnelles il y a des
y compris ouais j'ai vous citer un
exemple pour la première fois dans la
bombe dans la branche la ffb élabore les
banques pour la première fois le 1er
échelon sera en dessous du smic oui ça
veut dire qu'on est en train de
paupériser l'ensemble des travailleurs
c'est le résultat d'une négociation
interne non c'est le résultat
automatique du smic et d'un pays qui
importent incapable de réparer la
répartition de la valeur ajoutée de la
valeur créée dans l'entreprise autrement
que par les mesures législatives c'est à
dire qu'il ya une forme de en fait il ya
une forme de paresse du patronale des
branches professionnelles en disant oh
là le salaire minimum l'état s'en occupe
c'est le smic à une revalorisation
automatique
et puis bah
d'été dans les entreprises vous arrivez
pas imposer je suis ici depuis mois de
septembre on a réussi à revaloriser la
branche de la volaille l'hôtel k cafés
restaurants les travailleurs de
forestiers mais tout ça est rattrapé par
la pâle phénomène de l'inflation et donc
par le phénomène de revalorisation est
ce que je vous dis pas ce que je vous
dis là c'est si vous n'êtes pas smicard
aujourd'hui vous êtes juste au dessus
vous allez être rattrapés et l'inflation
vous la subissez quand même donc oui le
smic c'est important mais trop souvent y
compris dans le débat on entend que le
rôle des politiques pourraient être
justes sur le smic elle banon le rôle
des politiques
[Musique]
professionnels à
a amené des négociations ici elles ne
font pas avoir des sanctions le
gouvernement a aussi annoncé un dégel du
point d'indicé qui pourrait
éventuellement avoir lieu après
l'élection est ce que vous vous trouvez
électoralistes comme mature en tout cas
ce qui est sûr c'est de ne pas l'avoir
fait avant c'est fort de café parce que
l'inflation cinq ans l'inflation je sais
pas si 6 to tous nos auditeurs les
auditeurs le le savent mais ça touche
autant les agents publics que les agents
que les travailleurs du privé et donc ça
fait sept ans aujourd'hui vingt cinq ans
parce que la dernière fois c'était juste
avant l'élection présidentielle c'est
toi petite revalorisation est aussi sain
de mémoire et là c'est en gros ce sera
après donc ça fait pas le tout de la
politique salariale non plus dans les
fonctions publiques la valeur du point
mais là il est grand temps grand temps
d'augmenter la valeur du point il faut
l'augmenter de combien alors il faut
l'augmenter c'est pas la seule mesure
encore une fois mais il faut l'augmenter
au moins de trois points pour que l'on
puisse
répondre ajustée sur l'inflation elle a
juste et sur la façon je rappelle que ce
que je dis ce que j'ai dit sur le smic
ça concerne aussi les échelons les plus
bas dans les fonctions publiques lorsque
vous agents de catégorie c dans nombre
de fonctions publiques ou démarrer en
dessous du smic alors vous avez une
compensation mais quand vous franchissez
les échelons et bien vous vous êtes
toujours au smic et d'une manière
générale il faut indexer les salaires
sur l'inflation
oui il faudrait indexés en tout cas de
il faut laisser de la place à la
négociation parce qu'il ya des
entreprises il faut être très juste il
ya des entreprises où les négociations
salariales se déroule correctement parce
qu'il ya une compréhension de ce qui
pèse aujourd'hui sur votre ailleurs je
rappelle que l'inflation c'est pas de la
responsabilité de destra des
travailleurs c'est lié aux dépenses
contraintes notamment les questions
énergétiques
et c'est pas et c'est ça montre une
déficit structurel dans la répartition
de la valeur créée dans les entreprises
et donc c'est aux entreprises d'y
pallier par la valeur créée on parlait
de l'ambiance sur les élections prouvé
dans les élections présidentielles tout
à l'heure l'ambiance quand vous êtes un
salarié vous faites votre boulot et que
vous êtes payés au smic et l'année
d'après vous avez vous vous grimper un
échelon qui est prévu dans l'ombre aux
professionnels vous êtes de nouveau payé
au smic et l'année d'après vous le fait
que vous soyez dans le public ou dans le
privé c'est pareil vous continuez d'être
payés au smic balla
de non reconnaissance quand je parlais
tout à l'heure et donc de fatigue
démocrate alors justement parmi les
propositions des candidats table oui il
y en a une qui fait déjà beaucoup débat
qu'est ce que vous pensez de la
proposition d'assortir le rsa de
contrepartie
clairement elle me fait bondir cette
proposition elle et de plusieurs
candidats ça c'est pas nouveau on l'a
connu dans l'histoire c'est une forme de
2,2 de curepipe culpabilisation des
personnes les plus fragiles on parle de
formation d'ateliers pour vous essayer
de la culpabilisation non c'est là mais
là dans ce cas faut parler de
l'accompagnement ça et moi j'étais
conseiller en insertion professionnelle
chez très bien ce que sont les ce que
sont les personnes qui subissent
aujourd'hui des situations de pauvreté
outre agilité et qui doivent parce que
il faut pour survivre parce que là pour
le coup vivre aussi les perçoivent le
rsa ou le rmi avant il ya un an il ya
une obligation de la puissance publique
un accompagnement cet accompagnement
c'est la formation c'est de l'aide c'est
de l'aide à l'insertion professionnelle
c'est de l'être concrètes pour réaliser
un cv etc oui mais c'est que ça
s'appelle pas de la contrepartie c'est
moi depuis il ya eu un peu de
rétropédalage des uns et des autres il
faut faire attention
mais l'idée derrière
l'idée c'est que quand on est un peu
pauvre c'est quand même un peu bien de
sa faute quoi quand on l'a on subit là
bas il ya un peu de ça et mes mains mes
tendances et fond sur yon soyons très
honnête soyons très honnête
malheureusement c'est quelque chose qui
est assez répandu dans l'opinion
publique on le sait toutes les enquêtes
d'opinion nous montre ben moi c'est
quelque chose sur lequel on porte en
faux et vous voyez je suis pas du genre
à m'indigner en permanence bassam
indigne ça m'indigne samandin qu'on
puisse croire que des personnes des
familles vive avec un rsa et qui se
démène pour lutter contre l' une
situation de pauvreté soient considérés
comme des profiteurs
géant américain mais c'est jamais le cas
qu'un journaliste fasse mal son boulot
si vous voyez ce que je veux dire et
tous les journalistes font mal leur
boulot non ça peut paraître un retour
pour des gens qui s'éloigne de plus et
un accompagnement mais nous on est pour
un accompagnement mais dans les mesures
vous m'avez parlé c'est parler pas
d'accompagnement c'était une
contrepartie en guise d'activité au
début on a même pu comprendre les
candidats qui l'aurait travaillent
manuellement et d'autres candidats qui
propose plutôt des travaux d'intérêt
général ou d'intérêt général c'est juste
scandaleux d'abord tout travail mérite
salaire on est d'accord et puis un
travail d'intérêt général quand on
utilise ce terme ça une décision un sens
de justice on sait pas ce que vous avez
fait une erreur une faute car quelle
photo on fait les gens qui sont au rsa
donc là ça passe est un terme qui n'est
pas acceptable et si c'est un travail en
contrepartie du rsa tout travail mérite
salaire quinze heures par semaine un
travail et bien c'est plus que le rsa au
smic donc ce n'est pas acceptable et
puis pour ceux qui proposent un
accompagnement qui le disent clairement
c'est un accompagnement
un compagnon qui sera dans
l'actualité c'est les retraites moi j'ai
ouï emmanuel macron et et valérie
pécresse propose une retraite à 65 ans
est-ce que c'est nécessaire pour
équilibrer le système léger clé les
études montrent que pour équilibrer
système des retraites à moyen et long
terme on n'a pas besoin de reporter
l'âge légal de départ en retraite non
non un déficit de 2 milliards 6 en 2021
oui et puis il y à une reprise et une
situation de l'emploi qui qui s'est
amélioré et qu'ils résorbent les
déficits mais toutes les enquêtes les et
les études montrent y compris celle du
corps que sur le moyen et long terme le
système de retraite par répartition
n'est pas fragile financièrement donc ce
qui ne veut pas dire que il n'ya pas des
choses à faire évoluer dans le système
des retraites mais on est bien loin on
est bien loin d'une amélioration
qualitative du système des retraites en
réduisant les inégalités que subissent
les femmes ceux qui ont des carrières
longues ce qu'ont commencé quand des
métiers pénibles ceux qui ont des
carrières hachées qui sont souvent là où
ça fait partie de leur réforme de
retraites à 65 ans avec justement les
carrières longues avec la prise en
compte de la pénibilité oui mais le
renfort de pour le report de l'âge légal
soyons clairs le report de l'âge légal à
65 ans il touche qui il touche parce
qu'on liquide sa retraite aujourd'hui
autour de 63 64 en
mai mais il ya aussi ceux qui le liquide
qui l'a liquide parce qu'ils ont
commencé à travailler jeunes à 60 ans
cela ils vont travailler jusqu'à 62 ou
63 ans a travaillé à 60 ans ils ont
commencé à travailler jeunes
je veux dire c'est qu'ils liquident leur
retraite à 60 ans parce que il ya le
dispositif de carrières longues que la
cfdt avait obtenu en 2003 mais il n'a
pas bougé ce dispositif ah bon j'ai pas
que j'ai pas d'assurance à suivre ils
peuvent vous pensez qu'il peut être
juste et retardé pour lui je pense que
dans ce qui a en préparation ça peut
être ça ouais et donc ce que je dis là
dessus c'est que de toute façon dans le
contexte qu'on décrit la de difficultés
de fatigue démocratique de difficultés
sociales pour une partie des des
travailleurs et encore une fois pas pour
tout ça je suis pas dans le
misérabilisme mais de tension
de fatigue coin je suis pas sûr que
d'annoncer une mesure comme ça et de se
dire on va le faire à la hussarde soit
une bonne nouvelle ce qui est sûr c'est
qu'un la cfdt est contre le report de
l'âge légal à la retraite à 65 ans on
est contre aujourd'hui on fera compte
dans deux mois 2 ça veut pas dire qu'on
n'est pas on pense pas que il faut un
système beaucoup plus juste ça nécessite
pas de reporter l'âge légal de départ à
la retraite donc c'est clair et net pour
nous quasiment pas tous nos voisins
européens partent à la retraite en
moyenne quatre ans après nous gentil
mais d'abord nos voisins européens ils
n'ont pas tous la même démographie que
nous on est d'accord et là ce dont on a
entendu parler pendant la campagne
c'était qu'il fallait travailler plus
longtemps pour financer d'autres
éléments de la protection sociale c'est
très différent de ce qu'on a entendu de
ce qu'on a su faire il compris avec les
conséquences pour lancer les logiques
par an
c'est quand même parce que ça serait pas
pendant longtemps la cfdt est la part au
chien lorsqu'il fallait y compris report
avoir une durée de cotisation plus
longue elle n'a pas rechigné parce que
safin sas à équilibrer le système de
retraite par répartition et moi là
dessus j'ai pas d'état d'âme parce que
ce système c'est un joyau que pour
l'ensemble des générations et pour les
travailleurs là ce dont il s'agit c'est
financé peut-être d'autres risques au
sens perte d'autonomie là il ya d'autres
manières de le faire peut-être en
faisant en faisant contribuer l'ensemble
des revenus parce qu'il vous aura pas
échappé que en faisant travailler en
faisant peser ça sur un report de l'âge
légal on fait poser sa sur les
travailleurs ont fait pas peser ca sur
l'ensemble des revenus si vous allez sur
la transmission puisque vous voulez
parler du financement de la perte
d'autonomie si vous allez sur la
transmission à la transmission du
patrimoine qu'il y ait un débat sur les
droits de succession et c'est tout un
débat est franchement y'a pas vraiment à
la hauteur si je peux être très franc et
soutint débat on donne le sentiment que
que que la taxation des nôtres lattre la
transmission des patrimoines c'est un
sujet horrible de notre pays dix pour
cent de la population détient 50% du
patrimoine c'est clair ça profite aux
plus riches et on devient de plus en
plus c'est pas moi qui le dit c'est dé
tout un tas d'études qui le lisent en
une société de rentiers et bien si vous
faites vous taxent y ait
eu la transmission de patrimoine vous
financez
combien film
philosophiquement la transmission
moyenne c'est un fait ce qu'on reçoit en
moyenne ces vingt mille euros
philosophiquement on pourrait dire des
premiers euros ça ferait 200 euros pour
une personne qui reçoit 20 milles vous
voyez que c'est pas mais pour celles qui
posent les personnes qui reçoivent un
milliard de milliards 3 milliards ça
commence à faire du chiffre et moi je
pense que c'est beaucoup plus juste que
demander un travail et il ya un sujet
dont on vous avait dit on parle pas
beaucoup d'emplois tout à l'heure dans
votre introduction on parle pas beaucoup
n'ont plus de travail dans cette
campagne pas suffisamment de travail
quand on parle de retraite j'aimerais
bien qu'on parle du travail il ya la
moitié des gens qui un 40 % des gens qui
liquident leur trailer que la retraite
qui ne sont plus en emploi on parle pas
de difficultés d'emploi d'usure au
travail on ne parle pas de d'aménagement
des femmes carrière on parle pas de
seniors qui sont foutus dehors parce
qu'on les considère moins productifs
c'est donc parlons plus du travail puis
on parlera après des fins de carrière il
nous est opposé à la retraite à 65 ans
ça veut dire que le 25 avril vous êtes
dans la russie à 7
sa réforme qui est mise en place ça se
résume pas comme ça ce qui est sûr c'est
que la cfdt est contre et prendra les
moyens que vous combattrez sur
le 25 avril vous croyez vous croyez
qu'on n'aura pas ce sera vraiment le
moment de le faire il faudra voir
comment ces choses-là
de travail dans vos propositions du
pacte de pouvoir de vivre figurent le
compte épargne temps tout au long de la
vie d'entreprise en entreprise est-ce
que c'est pas une usine à gaz cette
proposition non c'est pas une usine à
gaz
parce que
c'est clair dans sa vie dans sa carrière
un moment donné c'est la particularité
du marché du travail français j'aime pas
trop le marché ultra est le terreau
marché du travail mais c'est quoi ces
camps gros vous bossez comme vous vous
êtes en précarité au début de votre
carrière où c'est difficile de rentrer
sur le marché du travail un peu moins
ces temps ci pour certains mais encore
pour d'autres et puis vous êtes mis
dehors avant l'âge légal de rhodes de
retraite parce que vous êtes trop vieux
et pas assez productif et puis entre
temps vous bossez comme un dingue quand
même avec on est quand même un des pays
les plus produits avec la productivité
la plus haute un don que moi j'entends
tout ce qu'il dira avec les français
travaillent pas et c etc mais et sur le
compte épargne temps et bien le compte
épargne temps on a besoin de temps en
temps des temps de respiration pour un
projet personnel pour s'occuper des
siens pour pour repenser peut-être sa
carrière professionnelle est ce qu'on a
envie de faire peut-être pendant un
certaine période d'avoir pendant de
travailler que trois jours par semaine
pendant trois mois cette pratique on
peut ce matin
vous êtes moins payés nous ont dit bah
oui mais et c'est possible pour certains
si l'on a compté par exemple mais pour
les autres non non non ça va pas
beaucoup de rions pas
je prends un exemple très concret vous
êtes embauché dans une entreprise vous
avez un énorme contée par une tante je
sais pas moi plusieurs semaines
votre entreprise elle vous dit eh bien
non je veux pas vous embaucher parce que
vous arrivez avec votre énorme boulet
votre compte épargne temps on veut pas
vous le financier ça risque pas d'être
été le même argument qui étaient en bout
employés sur le compte personnel de
formation c'est la même chose s'est
passé c'est pas si simple à mettre en
place le compte personnel de formation a
en tout cas il est transférable d'une
entreprise à l'autre il appartient au
salarié et donc c'est moi je crois qu'il
va falloir rentrer dans une
c'est ce que nous a appris le coc vide
c'est que l'articulation entre le temps
personnel étant professeur a été
extrêmement important et qu'on pouvait
innover créer et donc si rien n'est
possible sinon de dire aux gens vous
continuer de bosser comme avant on
s'occupe assez peu du travail on n'en
parle pas les conditions de travail tout
ça finalement maintenant c'est que ces
peinard les gens peuvent télétravail et
ce qui est évidemment le cas de 30 % des
salariés beaucoup pour beaucoup d'autres
c'est pas le cas et ce qui t'est travail
c'est loin d'être le nirvana tout le
temps et puis on peut rien inventé
d'intelligent parce que maintenant ben
voilà c'est de la sueur et des larmes je
suis pas sûr que en termes de fatigue
démocratique qu'on soit pas sur la
mauvaise pente où est ce que je veux
dire c'est on peut essayer d'y réfléchir
on l'a fait sur le compte personnel de
formation nous on l'avait fait sur le
compte personnel d'activités qui étaient
des droits transférables ça a été
abandonné après 2017 mais il ya des
choses à créer comme ça ils sont le
compte épargne temps universel moi je
crois qu'il ya des choses intelligentes
à construire avec des droits qui serait
alimenté pour nourrir ce compte épargne
temps universel qui permettrait aussi de
réduire des disques des disparités qui
existent dans le monde du travail et qui
sont mal vécues mais c'est très complexe
à ce que vous craignez pas qu'il ait le
même destin que par exemple la retraite
à points que vous souhaitiez ardemment
qui a été finalement 6-1 qu'ovide au
moment où on est on prend le construire
oui mais attendez la retraite venez voir
des mines et c'est bien la retraite à
points c'était un système où la retraite
à points nous on s'en fiche le point un
système universel des retraites oui moi
considérer qu'il est normal que les
avait vu les attendait mais personne
mais il y avait un âge où il a aussi
calé avec un nom mais justement on l'a
combattu les utiliser plus sur la table
quand le taux vide est arrivé où
celles-ci on peut plus rien inventé si
la question on va parler de l'avenir du
syndicalisme si l'avenir du syndicalisme
c'est de considérer que toutes choses
égales par ailleurs rien ne doit bouger
et que le bonheur des salariés et fait
aujourd'hui baba la réponse elle est non
conservé une dernière question puisqu'on
parle quand même des retraites est ce
que vous êtes favorable à la suppression
des régimes spéciaux
je crois qu'on en fait trop avec sur les
régimes spéciaux regardez ce qui se
passe c'est la sncf année c'est plus
rare et plus régime spécial il est en
train de s'éteindre parce que il ya eu à
la clause du grand père c'est ce qui est
d'ailleurs promis par certains sur dans
cette campagne présidentielle ça y est
les régimes spéciaux qui sont souvent la
contrepartie de salaires qui sont a
accès parce qu'ils sont bas donc moi je
crois qu'il faut réfléchir avec les
aigles et salariés concernés avec les
représentants du personnel concernées la
façon dont fait le régime donc le la
cfdt couleurs c'est quand même qu'il va
falloir mais a terminé avec l'aja
système universel on n'a pas bougé là
dessus à terme on pense qu'il ya un
système universel
ça va être compliqué pour l'instant
c'est pas une dernière question oui sur
cette idée d'avoir le versement à la
source des des allocations est ce que
vous vous y êtes favorable que vous
trouvez que c'est une bonne idée c'est
pas forcément une mauvaise idée ouais
c'est mémé tout ça ça descend ça
dépendra de comment comment s'est opéré
c'est le le si on parle des minima
sociaux notamment du rsa ou d'autres et
il en existe d'autres il ya un vrai
problème de non recours et et ça pose un
problème c'est à dire que des gens qui
auraient droit à un
client un droit nous on n'y ont pas
accès si on le faisait en uniformisant
les bases ressources des personnes et
qu'on était capable de leur ville de
leur verser automatiquement le minima
social auquel ils ont droit ce serait
une avancée mais tout ça doit se
construire avec les associations qui
sont compétentes en la matière ont parlé
d' expertise il ya beaucoup d' expertise
là dessus et que la solution avec
laquelle on travaille nous dans le pack
du pouvoir de vivre il a ce sont de
lutte contre la pauvreté contre
l'exclusion faut le faire avec elle il
faut le faire pas pour baisser les
droits pour qu'ils aient plus des gens
qui accèdent aux droits et plus de
droits beaucoup de questions merci pour
ces réponses très précises merci
brigitte merci tam dans un instant
extraire jaurès ou en attendant que yves
s'installe en face de vous il ya une
polémique aujourd'hui entre le candidat
macron et le candidat jean luc mélenchon
autour de l'idée
de
de sensibiliser les élèves de 12 ans à
partir de 12 ans à l'apprentissage jean
luc mélenchon a dénoncé la volonté de
faire des élèves très jeune dès 12 ans
des apprentis manuel macro ont réagi
très
très vigoureusement ce matin sur nos
consoles chez nos confrères de france
inter en disant c'est une fête nous on
veut sensibiliser des douze ans aux
métiers ou fait de travailler et à
l'apprentissage
d'abord quand il ya polémique entre des
candidats c'est pas tellement à moi de
les départager et j'ai pas une idée
claire mans sur le fond l'apprentissage
est un bon système à 12 ans on peut pas
être apprenti ouais c'est ça le sujet
évidemment nous on ne peut pas on va pas
de vouloir que des enfants soient
apprentis à 12 ans il m'aime je crois à
14 ans avec un statut d'apprendre
d'apprentissage ceci étant pour nombre
de jeunes avoir une connaissance de ce
que peuvent être des métiers c'est pas
forcément négatif mais non
l'apprentissage chez à 16 ans
aujourd'hui et c'est très bien ainsi il
faut développer l'apprentissage à à 16
ans parce que c'est une voie qui est une
voie très positif pour nombre de jeunes
et notamment des jeunes aujourd'hui il
affronta chez beaucoup développé tout le
monde s'en réjouit mais il s'est
beaucoup développée pour les formations
supérieures c'est une bonne chose très
bien mais il faut aussi le faire pour
pour des jeunes avec des formations
comme on dit de niveau 5 c'est-à-dire de
après après la troisième parce que c'est
aussi pour certains d'entre eux une voix
figaro
si vous permettez j'ai un petit droit de
suite donc on va
naviguer sur des sujets vous avez
peut-être déjà évoquée mais que vous
n'avez pas complètement développé sur
l'ukraine je sais que c'est vous et
c'est un sujet qui est cher qui vous est
cher c'est celui des réfugiés est ce que
vous estimez qu'on en fait assez nous la
france l'europe déjà et nous la france
singulièrement pour accueillir ces
réfugiés s'est réfugié ukrainien en
l'occurrence l'europe elle a été sur la
question des réfugiés ukrainien est là
elle s'est mobilisée et elle a créé ce
statut spécial un peu plus rapide pour
accéder à l'azile c'est une très bonne
chose il faut maintenant je crois moi
une des voies sur laquelle l'europe doit
progresser c'est mutualisés parce que ça
peut pas reposer majoritairement sur les
pays frontalier de l'ukraine il faut
mutualiser ce qu'on a malheureusement
pas su faire avec l'italie à un moment
donné lalala l'accueil et la prise en
charge de ces réfugiés et compris en le
finançant d'un niveau européen et on en
prend suffisamment notre part justement
il faut qu'on la prenne nous on est à
mobiliser aujourd'hui y compris à
travers nos équipes d'entreprises pour
regarder là où il ya des logements oui
parfois dans des lieux ou aux ex comités
d'entreprise au cse et des logements
liées à vos retours des centres de
vacances et tard on essaie de regarder
nous on a même proposé de mettre à
disposition une partie des locaux de
notre local de notre centre de formation
voilà donc on peut je crois il faut
qu'on y prenne tous notre part
mais moi j'ai alerté avec delphine julio
qui est la directrice de france terre
d'asile j'ai alerté sur le fait qu'il
faut traiter de la même manière les
personnes qui fuient la guerre en
ukraine qu'ils soient ukrainien mariées
à des ukrainiens ou qu'ils soient de
pays tiers
il ya l'europe et la france en
particulier sont pas très pas très
courageux faire passer les personnes qui
étaient par exemple étudiants ah oui des
congolais qui était par exemple voilà et
qui fuient la guerre comme les autres et
qui doivent être accueillis et d'avoir
le même statut d'accueil que que les
personnes qui est en ukraine moi j'ai
écrit on a écrit avec des files
rouilleault une tribune sur le sujet on
a interpellé le gouvernement je pense
qu'il faut il faut le faire mais oui sur
l'accueil de réfugiés c'est une
mobilisation collective ya beaucoup
d'absents spi ration de mobilisation
citoyenne moi je peux vous dire qu'on
organise aussi on s'organise al interne
pour essayer de sensibiliser nos
militants ça s'apprend très bien on va
se le dire il ya beaucoup de solidarité
qui s'exprime même faire alors c'est pas
le sujet des réfugiés mais on va me
faire un convoi va y avoir un convoi
syndicale qui va partir vers l'ukraine
en lui la cfdt des organisations
syndicales françaises des organisations
syndicales françaises pas que la cfdt
cgt la cftc force ouvrière
et donc on va on va organiser un convoi
syndicales ont un lien avec nos
partenaires collègues syndicaux
ukrainien pour là à les aider
concrètement la population qui est qui
est resté en ukraine alors nous sommes
dans une période électorale et on a
passé un quinquennat après d'autres
quinquennat où on a vu que le dialogue
social est bien n'est pas là il n'y a
pas de dialogue c'est toujours le bras
de fer quand les réformes sont engagées
est ce que il faut revoir les méthodes
de dialogue en france s'inspire et
peut-être de ce qui se passe en
allemagne dans les pays scandinaves
il est question d'une réforme
institutionnelle est ce que justement à
la faveur de cette réforme
institutionnelle qui n'a pas eu lieu eh
bien il faut
réfléchir à la façon d'améliorer le
dialogue social pour éviter ces bâtons
il peut y avoir une réforme
institutionnelle on peut inscrire le
dialogue social dans la constitution
tout ça c'est dans les mentalités mais
c'est les acteurs observé moi je suis
très inspirée du fameux rapport qui
avait été un rapport combrexelle sur la
place du dialogue social dans notre
société est le premier chapitre était
sur le comportement des acteurs je crois
puisqu'on est avec son présidentiel on
s'adresse un peu à ceux qui demain ceux
et celles qui pourrait diriger ce pays
il faut une autre conception du dialogue
social et de la place des corps
intermédiaires dans notre dans notre
pays on leur a posé la question parce
qu'on a reçu les candidats ou leurs
représentants cfdt pour une audition on
leur a tous posé la question
l'attachement à la démocratie sociale au
syndicalisme ils sont tous très attachés
maintenant nous c'est pas tant de
déclarations qu'on veut que de preuves
de preuves concrètes donc je crois que
c'est on peut pas dire qu'aujourd'hui à
chaque fois qu'ils aimeraient forme on
trouve en face des arias o saya elles
qui sont pas d'accord qui ont qui
moralise
allez c'est pas tout je crois qu'il ya
une possibilité de co construction dans
ce pays mais d'un vrai qu'on
construction pas de l'art ou alors ça
passe par le fait qu'on puisse organiser
un temps pour s'approprier ce qui est de
la réalité et la réalité ne doit pas
venir qu un peu mon temps où elle va
devenir l' expertise de terrain dont je
parlais tout à l'heure un temps où on
regarde ce qu'il faut faire évoluer et
qu'ils soient pas toujours de la sueur
et des larmes mais aussi des avancées
qualitatives concrètes et puis un temps
où on codécider on s'engage et vous
savez on a on l'a fait récemment sa part
je vais vous dire on l'a fait sur
quelque chose qui est passée inaperçue
qui décident 4 cac a permis de sauver
des milliers et des dizaines de milliers
d'emplois la location partielle longue
durée chez marc séné ou séné dans une
discussion avec le ministre la ministre
du travail puis ensuite avec matignon
puis avec l'elysée dans une réunion qui
a eu lieu je crois le 10 juillet 2020 où
l'ensemble des organisations syndicales
et patronales de ce pays avait dire ben
ok on a des accords sur autre chose mais
là on va s'engager là dedans et les
entre les dents dans les entreprises il
ya eu négociation de ces accords qui ont
permis de passer le cap et ensuite de
pouvoir ne pas supprimer d'emplois je
voudrais un contre exemple le président
de la république s'était engagé sur
l'écologie et dieu sait si vous êtes
attaché à ce sujet puisque vous avez
fait un rapport justement avec que
nicolas hulot sur sa à ce qui est un
excellent une expérience de démocratie
participative
je prendrai tout disait-il à l'exception
de deux ou trois mesures il n'a rien
pris du tout tout ça est resté en plan
ça n'a pas marché la démocratie
participative c'est transforme en un
gadget risible pour tout le monde je je
je trouve que là si vous êtes qui vous
caricaturez il je crois que le président
avait dit qu'il se prendrait tout il n'a
pas tout prix ouais rien pris c'est
beaucoup dire qu'il a rien appris dans
la loi non mais vous et moi je ce que
j'essaye de faire dans ce bazar ambiant
un peu dans le débat public c'est
d'essayer de mettre deux un peu ce
qu'est la réalité et la nuit et la
nuance non non pas de lord pas mon
domaine mais la nuance il a pas tout
prix mais ce qui est sûr c'est que cette
convention citoyenne sur le climat elle
a été un vrai exercice démocratique et
malheureusement il n'y a pas eu le
respect de l'engagement du départ mais
il ya eu ça a permis des avancées
moi je crois que sur un certain nombre
de sujets il faut en appeler aux
citoyens et à leur intelligence
collective il est alors confrontation
des différents coins du lido sur
d'autres sujets il y à des organisations
qui sont là bas on s'appuie pas assez
dans notre pays tout le monde le sait
sur le réseau associatif il ya un
formidable réseau associatif mais on les
cantonne à l'heure alors si tu as qu'il
gère ce qui sort de ceux dont il
s'occupe mais on passait à leur
expertise notamment en termes
d'éducation populaire vous savez les
gueules sont populaires c'est on apprend
les uns avec les autres on apprend les
uns par les autres ça on fait plus on
fait pas à ses fins il y en a plein qui
font mais on devait passer en valeur
donc moi je crois que gouverner demain
encore plus qu'hier c'est faire vivre
trois démos trois éléments non
démocratie et le premier c'est la
démocratie représentative on est élu on
est légitime pour le faire la deuxième
c'est la démocratie participative les
citoyens de plus en plus ils veulent
participer aux tueries comme ça mais
faut pas oublier la démocratie sociale
il y a aujourd'hui des corps
intermédiaires dans ce pays on frappa
sens qu'on va mal d'accord alors
justement vous êtes à la tête de la cfdt
premier syndicat de france il faut le
dire y compris dans le privé pub privés
et publics et vous avez un congrès au
mois de juin entre les deux tours des
législatives ce qui n'est pas banal et
vous allez-vous faire réélire
triomphalement il ya aussi eu aucun
suspense mais alors il ya une curiosité
c'est que vous allez normalement
abandonnez votre
mandat en milieu en cours de mandat
peut-être dans deux ans on a fixé la
date ya longtemps on savait pas que ce
serait les entre les deux tours des
législatives
d'abord j'ai pas donné de date 2 c'est
une coutume usage chez nous qui est
possible c'est ce que j'ai fait avec
françois chérèque il est parti je suis
arrivé en cours de mandat chez nous on a
une règle c'est qu'on fait autour de dix
ans plus ou moins deux ans et moi je me
tiens à dire que la cfdt s'est pas
laurent berger et laurent bergé s'est
pas classé avec l'été non plus
d'ailleurs mais et donc du coup c'est
normal qu'on fasse vivre notre notre
fonctionnement démocratique à l'ayant
régulièrement des changements de
responsables donc pendant ce mandat
et vous savez pas quand si ce sera deux
en un an trois ans quatre ans peut-être
juste avant le prochain
mais en cours de mandat c'est clair il y
aura un changement de responsable la
cfdt je crois que c'est sain ça peut
être une femme d'ailleurs qui vous
succède un homme et une femme oui
bon on parle de beaucoup de gens y vont
mais c'est aujourd'hui c'est la
secrétaire général adjoint de la cgt
c'est quelqu'un qui sera et tous les
jours que j'apprécie cas beaucoup
compétences mais il ya beaucoup de gens
aujourd'hui qu'ont beaucoup de
compétences quel est le défi auquel vous
allez soumettre le prochain ou la
prochaine présidente de la république
retrouve le savait mais le sujet qui
vous tient à coeur en fête pour dire
celui joue enfin celui de la justice
sociale c'est à dire que je crois que
les travailleurs il ils sont attachés à
leur travail ils veulent être justement
reconnues ils veulent une protection
sociale qui les protège et donc c'est
celui de je crois de la reconnaissance
du travail c'est la reconnaissance du
travail qui ne soit pas faut travailler
plus pour gagner plus sa
formule a été prononcé samedi par le
président de la république sortant oui
mais je crois que la reconnaissance du
travail c'est celle écoute des
travailleurs c'est prendre en
considération ceux qui sont les plus les
plus en difficulté vous savez on a
beaucoup applaudi ya deux ans on
applaudissait tous ces travailleurs de
deuxième ligne depuis il y en a trop qui
n'ont pas été reconnues à leur juste
implication et leur juste valeur donc ce
sera celui-là et puis un deuxième quand
même si je peux me permettre c'est on a
face à nous dans un mur c'est un mur
écologique on n'a pas beaucoup parlé
mais c'est le mur de la transition
écologique celui là on le prendra entre
étant à égalité la question écologique
et la question sociale c'est à dire en
les éloignant on a fait un rapport sur
l'automobile dont vous avez parlé de
foot voyez que c'est conciliables mais
bien sûr si c'est pas conciliables on la
fera pas on ne fera ni l'un ni l'autre
et on ira là un choc démocratique il
faut que demain la question économique
se conjuguer avec les questions sociales
avec la question écologique et donc il
faudra pas oublier quelque chose de
fondamental dans tout ça ce sont les
travailleurs et travailleuses mais ses
créateurs d'emplois c'est
potentiellement créateurs d'emplois
c'est aussi destructeur d'emplois et
donc c'est ça nécessite beaucoup
d'accompagnement des hommes et des
femmes pour pour le faire avec eux et
pas contre eux on a commencé l'émission
vers l'ukraine on a parlé d'un risque
aussi d'élections d'extrêmement dont
vous ne voulez pas
savoir vous avez le moral en ce moment
ah oui j'ai une morale d'abord pour des
raisons personnelles
mais j'ai une morale aussi parce que
vous avez ça dépend que de nous les uns
et les autres ça dépend que de nous
alors il ya évidemment des événements
exogènes qu'on ne maîtrise pas comme
simple citoyen dimanche ça dépend que de
nous que des uns et des autres de faire
valoir leurs convictions et ensuite de
prendre leur part à la construction de
la société et pas d'accepter de dire que
quel que soit l'élu le 24 il aura la
possibilité de gouverner sans se
préoccuper des citoyens et des
citoyennes les citoyens et citoyennes
doivent avoir la prise sur les choix qui
les concernent c'est le mot de la fin
merci beaucoup leur jette rester avec
nous pendant sept heures d'émission dans
un indice ion public merci beaucoup on
se retrouve évidemment à 19h30 cp et
public sénat bonne semaine à tous ce
sera lendemain du premier tour
sacré semaines à venir bonne soirée
[Musique]